hello my name is kevin chevior and today
i will talk about the paper entitled
unknown iid profits better bounds
streaming algorithms and a new
impossibility
this is joint work with jose correa paul
duting felix fisher
and bruno silioto in this paper we
revisit
profit inequalities for iid random
variables from an unknown distribution
and consider the three aspects mentioned
in the title
for a little background i will first
talk about the iid profit inequality
that is the profit inequality for iid
random variables
from known distribution this inequality
refers to the following mathematically
very clean setting
so there is a distribution f on the
positive real numbers
and the natural number n known up front
and now a decision maker is presented
with the sequence
of independent draws x1 up to xn
from this distribution f these draws are
also depicted up here
and now they will be revealed from the
left to the right
you know and the decision makers task is
to select a single one of these draws at
the time when the straw is revealed
we refer to the selected draw as x tau
where tau is also called stopping time
let's go through a quick example of how
this process works
so first x1 is revealed you know let's
say it's eight
and the decision maker has to decide
whether to select this value
or not let's say knowing f the decision
maker
decides not to select this value no
and now x2 is revealed and turns out
that value is 5. the decision maker may
again decide not to select this value
then x3 is revealed turns out to be 13.
now the decision maker may say let's
select this value
then tau will be set to 3 and
all other draws no matter what their
values are
are automatically rejected because
the decision maker may only select a
single
one of the draws so that's the setting
now what does the profit inequality say
about the setting
well it compares the expected value
that the decision maker can select
with the expected value of the profit
that is the expected value that an
all-knowing profit would select
when they would see all the draws up
front
yeah so this is precisely the expected
maximum of all the draws
so more specifically the iid profit
inequality says
that there is a stopping rule for the
decision maker
such that for all and f uh the expected
value that
the decision maker selects using the
stopping rule
uh is at least an alpha fraction
of uh the value of the profit
where this alpha is a number that
doesn't have a closed form expression
and is roughly 0.745
this inequality with this precise
constant is due to an
you see 17 paper by korea and others
and it matches in fact an impossibility
result
due to hillary cards from the adults of
probability of
82. so this constant alpha here on the
right hand side
is in fact best possible okay
so this is the iid profit inequality
let me also say a few words about
applications
that have caused quite some interest in
profit inequalities in the past few
years
and in fact also quite some nice results
on profit inequalities
so one application is in mechanism
design at algorithmic pricing
because one may imagine
these draws as valuations of customers
for a certain product a second
application is in beyond the worst case
analysis of online algorithms
because one may interpret what i just
told you as
beyond the worst case analysis of an
online version of the very simple
problem of selecting the maximum of a
sequence
what arguably makes results for this and
related models however less applicable
in the real world
is the strong assumption that
the distribution f is precisely known
you know and this strong assumption will
be relaxed in the next model that i will
talk about
where uh we'll assume that only k
samples for some number k
um from f are known and we'll refer to
these samples as
s1 up to sk
this precise model has been introduced
in an ec19 paper
by a subset of the authors of this paper
but a similar assumption had been made
before for
related models by azer kleinberg and
weinberg in the sort of 14
paper a major goal of the research into
this problem
has been getting a similar kind of
guarantee as for the previous problem
so more precisely the goal can be
formulated as
finding a point with largest function
alpha that
gets as input um the number of samples
and the number of values on which the
decision maker and profit can stop
and output some guarantee between 0 and
1
with the following property there exists
a stopping rule
that an expectation selects a value
that's
at least the corresponding value of
alpha
times the value of the profit
and that should hold for every number
of values and for every
distribution f some remarks about this
well first off such settings usually
become
most mathematically clean and
interesting
when n is large so we'll in fact later
consider a large n
also as we showed in the c19 paper
when the number of samples is sublinear
in n
then the best possible guarantee
one can find here is essentially one
over e
up to uh terms that vanish when
n becomes larger on the other end of the
spectrum
it was shown in last year's version of
this conference by rubenstein wang and
weinberg
that the guarantee of roughly 0.745
from the known distribution setting can
already be
approximately achieved with a linear
number of samples
now so in other words
the setting when the number of samples
is sub linear and
n is essentially understood
and there's no need to
use a super linear number of samples
therefore
really the most interesting setting is
the linear regime
namely when the number of samples is
linear in
n you know and therefore we will from
now on focus on this
linear regime so let's say
from now on we have beta times n samples
and we are looking for the achievable
guarantee
as a function of beta yeah
and since we are really interested in
the setting where n is large
we don't care about additive terms
in the guarantee that vanish when n
becomes large
so what's known about this achievable
guarantee as a function of beta
i'm showing here the original bounds
from the ec19 paper
on left you can see
upper and lower bounds on that guarantee
um
really as a function of beta and on the
right you can
see the slice for beta equals one
also the lower and upper bound let me
remark a few things about this
so let's first talk about this upper
bound curve here
so because we have guarantees that are
smaller than one
these upper bounds correspond to
impossibility results
that is results of the form there's no
stopping rule with a guarantee better
than
something okay so um yeah
so this tight upper bound here uh
for beta equals one um comes from a
ramsey theoretic construction that i
won't repeat here anymore
but essentially all these yeah so all
these
upper bounds up to this point here of
beta roughly
uh 1.32 uh they
come from a simple extension of that
argument and at that point
um yeah this uh extended
um upper bound is dominated by uh
the upper bound bound of 0.745
from the non-distribution setting and
then on the lower bound side
um let me mention two stopping rules
um namely the the stopping move for beta
equals zero
which is the stopping rule from the
well-known secretary problem
and the stopping rule for beta equals
one a variation of which we'll talk
about later
and in fact all the bounds depicted here
they follow from
extensions of these two stopping rules
as i've mentioned earlier it is known
from itcs
20 that this lower bound here
approaches this upper bound for large
beta
but this presumably lossy analysis leads
to large values of beta
which are not part of this diagram
results which can however be drawn into
this diagram
are the results by kaplan nauri and rus
from soda 20 who get an improvement
for valleys of beta strictly between 0
and 1.
in particular they do not get an
improvement for
beta equals 1.
in a paper that appeared in the same
conference however
korea christie epstein and soto do get a
slight improvement
upon the lower bound for beta equals 1.
i've also drawn the straightforward
extension
of this bound to other values of beta
another thing i should mention about
these two papers
is that they consider slightly more
general settings
and that still
in this diagram the only tight bound
is the one for beta equals zero even
though in this area it may
look like the dashed line and the blue
line they coincide
in fact they don't with this background
in mind
we can understand the contribution of
this paper
as mentioned earlier the contribution of
this paper is three-fold
in that we extend um
yeah the state of the art for the
aforementioned problems
in three different directions the first
contribution is an improvement of the
state-of-the-art guarantee
for all values of beta larger than zero
again
excluding the large beta case of
obenstein and others from
itcs 20.
remarkably our results are tight for all
values of beta
between 0 and roughly 0.58
so except for beta equals 0 we thereby
obtain the first tight bounds
in addition we get tight bounds within a
natural class of algorithms
called mrs algorithms that i will define
in a minute
and we get these type bounds using
variational
calculus then as a second contribution
we introduced the streaming version of
the model
this version of the model addresses the
arguably unrealistic assumption
that all samples can be stored even if
it's a vast amount of samples
while for some algorithms it's unclear
how to implement them as streaming
algorithms
fortunately mrs algorithms can naturally
be implemented as streaming algorithms
in our model
okay so that's another advantage of
those mrs algorithms that we define
and then as a third contribution we
extend the one over e impossibility
that you saw on the previous slide to
exchangeable random variables
this solves the problem of hill and cats
from the 90s and while the techniques
are based on those ramsey theoretic
techniques
from the c19 paper the proof requires
significantly more effort and
in fact an application of kuhn's theorem
okay these are the contributions of the
paper
since i don't have time to talk about
all of them in detail
i will from now on focus on this first
contribution so let me first show you
the improved bounce we get
in the figure from the last slide
so um these bounds are now depicted in
red
most remarkably as i said uh
in the range of beta between 0
and 0.58 you know we get
tight we get a tight bound
and um for beta equals 1
we get a much more significant
improvement than that by corey and
others from
soda 20. but how do we get these bounds
i will now talk about the slight
variation of the algorithm from the
ec19 paper which is in fact the baseline
for our approach
so the idea is as follows at each step
the algorithm looks at all the values it
has seen
up until the previous step that is all
the
n minus one samples and uh or the
i minus one values on which it could
have stopped
okay and from this set of values it
selects a
uniformly random subset of size n
minus one and to decide whether or not
to select
a value x i this algorithm simply takes
the maximum of that
uniformly randomly chosen subset and
sets this value as threshold for
accepting x
i yeah so if x i surpasses this maximum
of the
subset then x i is selected
otherwise it is not and for the sake of
this talk we can simply assume
without loss of generality that f is
continuous
so the probability of a tie is in fact
zero
all right to analyze this approach
um we will use the following lemma
which says uh that conditioned on
arriving in some step i
the distribution of that uniformly
randomly
selected subset um is
the distribution of a set of n
minus one fresh samples from
a distribution f with this lemma at hand
it's quite easy to see
that this approach gives us a guarantee
of 1 minus 1 over e
so to see that first observe that
now the probability of a
accepting x i is one over n
with this lemma attend it's quite easy
to see that the
above approach gives us a guarantee of
one minus one over e
to see that uh let's first observe that
conditioned on arriving in step i the
probability
that we accept
that we accept x i is one over n this is
simply because
uh that subset
selected uniformly at random consisting
of n minus one fresh samples together
with x
i now forms a set of n fresh samples
and of course the probability that
x i is the largest of these values is 1
over n
and this happens if and only if the
above algorithm
accepts x i okay
and now we can do the following
computations
let's write the expected value that the
algorithm selects
as sum over all time steps i of
the probability of arriving in that time
step i
by the argument that i just gave that's
precisely this quantity
times the probability of
accepting in that
particular time step which is just 1
over
n so also just argued
and then we multiply that with
the expectation of
x i if it's selected by the algorithm
that last expectation again by noticing
that
x i together uh with this
selected subset forms a set of
n fresh samples is just the maximum
of n draws from the distribution
so it's precisely the profits value you
know
so if we move this part here out of the
sun
the only thing that's left to do is uh
to understand the sum here um
when n uh tends towards infinity and
it's well known
that this approaches uh 1 minus 1 over e
okay that's the whole analysis
but how do we get beyond 1 minus 1 over
e
well the idea is to vary the
cardinality of the selected subset
over time now and
this is formalized by mrs algorithms
an mrs algorithm is parameterized by a
function f
that maps each integer between one and n
to another integer which corresponds to
the coloniality
of uh the subset selected
in that time step and of course this
subset may not be too large
because we can only select a subset
of all the values we've seen thus far
and
this is really just the number of
samples plus
all values seen so far on which
yeah the algorithm could have stopped
and then this function is really used in
a natural way
so in each step i
the mrs algorithm selects
a uniformly random subset of size f i
from all draws seen so far
yeah and then the maximum of that subset
is used again
as a threshold for accepting x i
what's nice is that an analogous version
of the lemma from the previous slide
still holds so conditioned on arriving
in step i
the distribution of the
set of values selected at this time
is again the one of
a set of the corresponding number of
fresh samples
but which function should we use not so
clear
but let's start in a simple way and
let's keep looking at this case of n
minus 1 samples
yeah so this is a visualization of the
function we used before
for n equals 6.
as i mentioned earlier we have these
upper bounds on
the function values so because we have
only five samples available
um the first uh carnality
the carnality of the first chosen subset
may not
be larger than five and so on for the
next steps
um but yeah within these constraints we
could really imagine any crazy function
right
but before really considering any crazy
function
i first want to argue that we really
have an edge on this function that we
previously considered
by considering this larger class of
functions yeah
and to do so i want to consider um yeah
this type of function will assume that n
is divisible by 3
and then there will be these three parts
so for the first third of time
the function value will be as before
will be n minus one
um then for the second third of time uh
the function value will be
four thirds times n minus one and then
for the last third of time
um the function value will be two-thirds
times n
minus one now it's not hard to see that
in the first third conditioned on
accepting
the mrs algorithm will again get the
profits value
right in the second third however
conditioned on accepting
the algorithm will get the expected
maximum
of four thirds times n many draws from
the distribution
yeah and likewise in the last um
and the last third condition i'm
accepting the algorithm will get
the expected maximum of two-thirds times
n
many draws yeah now the crux of the
analysis
is how to trade these values against
each other
and on the next slide i will show you
yeah what seems to be exactly the right
way to do this
so this is the function from the last
slide written out formally
and the approach to
analyzing the mrs algorithm
parameterized with this function
is yeah exactly as before
so with sum overall time steps again
take the probability of
arriving in that time step times uh
probability of accepting in this time
step
times expected value extracted when
actually accepting in that time step but
now the sum will have three parts
corresponding to the three steps of our
step function
the first part however hasn't changed
because
also the first step still has the same
function values as before
yeah the only thing that's changed is
how i've written the expected maximum
of n draws from distribution f
okay um yeah and then we can actually go
on
in a very analogous way so let's
um actually give this probability of
accepting
in the first part a name namely t1
and then we can just use one minus t1
as the probability of arriving in second
step
yeah but then things are really the same
only that i need to replace n by
uh for thirds times n
yeah and then uh we can go on in a
similar way
uh again this probability we can express
as t2
and use that in the next line yeah
and then we can also express this here
as t3
but again of course we want to look at
large n
so let's take the limit and then
everything actually becomes much nicer
so let's in fact write this as a single
integral
um and now compare this with
yeah with the profits value which is
as i said earlier can be written this
way
now to compare these two integrals we'll
actually show something
seemingly stronger namely that no matter
what
f x to the n is you know
um the
integrand of this integral is at least
some constant that's larger than 1 minus
1 over e
times the integrand of this integral
yeah
so if we substitute f
f of x to the n by a the inequality that
we can show
for all values of a between 0 and 1
is the following yeah it's really what i
just said
and the constant we get there is
larger than 0.637 which is in turn
larger than
1 minus 1 over e by the way showing this
is really just a simple calculus problem
now
okay so we have seen we can improve one
minus one over e
fairly simply actually but how far can
we go with
mrs algorithm so probably that's not
the best we can do right so
we again don't just want to look at this
function but
at all kinds of crazy functions
and to find the right function
it often turns out that it's actually
easier
to find them among continuous functions
yeah
so if we have found the right continuous
function
uh and let's say we increase n then
we can also get the discrete values
again from this function but just
equidistantly sampling that function
then we might not have integers yet
but if we want them around the values we
do
so let's really look at continuous real
valued functions now
on the domain 0 1.
just for completeness again we don't
want our function to be up here because
then it would use larger subsets
than it can um and yeah the two
functions we've looked at so far is this
one
and this one which is strictly speaking
not continuous but
it would be easy to make it continuous
at a small loss in the guarantee
all right so how do we compute the best
continuous functional
well given such a function g let's first
express
the expected value of what the algorithm
selects
in terms of this function g i don't want
to go through this in detail
but this is really the continuous
version of what we've done before
yeah so this um this integral here
uh really corresponds to the sum of all
time steps
then this here corresponds to the um
uh to the probability of arriving in
in a particular time step that's the
probability of accepting
in a in that particular time step and
this is
the conditional expectation of the
accepted value
yeah and then in this next step
we move that integral to the outside as
we did before
um yeah also as before the profit
profits value is this doesn't change um
and by taking these two equations here
we now obtain this control problem here
we want to find a function g such that
the analogous version of that calculus
problem we had on the other slide
becomes as large as possible yeah
fortunately we managed to solve this
control problem using variational
calculus
but for the details i
would like to refer you to the paper
still i would like to show you the
solution that we get
which is this here so the
um probably best function g
uh is this here and it achieves a
guarantee of roughly
0.6534 note however that we haven't
imposed
any constraint on the number of samples
that the corresponding mrs algorithm may
use
so in fact here in the beginning
that algorithm uses one point roughly
1.4 times
and many samples which may well be too
much
so what happens if we really impose that
the graph of this function be not in
this area here
meaning that the corresponding mrs
algorithm
uses at most and samples
we strongly conjecture that
the best function has the following
property
namely that its function values
initially for some prefix
are as large as they can be and under
this conjecture
we again get the provably
best function g
and yeah the guarantee this function
achieves is roughly
0.649
all right and we have a similar picture
for other other upper bounds on the
number of samples that may be used
let's for instance increase the the
upper bound on the number of samples
that may be used
to 1.1 times n samples then we get this
picture
if we go to 1.2 times n samples then we
get this picture
and so on yeah until
we finally increase this upper bound to
roughly um 1.443
times n samples which is when this
constraint becomes redundant so let's
decrease this upper bound again
no um you can observe how the
um how the guarantee becomes worse and
worse
yeah so something interesting will
happen
when we reach uh roughly 0.5
8 times n samples so a number that i had
mentioned earlier
in fact multiple things happen so this
is the first time
that the mrs function that we get is
just a linear function
you know and also um
the bound that we get uh is tied
with respect to the impossibility that i
mentioned earlier
yeah so for n over e minus
one samples we now have a tight bound
of in fact also
one over e minus one one would hope that
this stays true as we further decrease
the upper bound on
the number of samples unfortunately this
is not the case
so for 0.5 times n samples we still get
a linear function
no but the bound that we get with it
is not tied anymore with respect to our
impossibility
fortunately uh we can get the tight
bound
by a slight modification of the
algorithm beyond mrs algorithms
the idea is to allow the algorithm to
skip some initial fraction of the values
and not accept them at all as indicated
here by
the missing function value and by doing
so and optimizing over the length of
this prefix
we again achieve a tight bond
and as we further decrease the upper
bound of the number of samples that may
be used
we still get tight bounds this way
all the way down to zero samples which
is when
the resulting algorithm
[Music]
matches the secretary algorithm
so on this paper we managed to get tight
bonds
for a whole range of values of beta
and improved bounds for many other
values of beta
i would also like to point you to
this paper by korea christie epstein and
soto
that appeared on the archive in november
of last year
and make some further progress towards
closing the gaps apart from that i would
like to thank you for your attention
and if you have any questions feel free
to approach me at the conference
or write me an email